what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started also guys before I start make
sure you get yourself a women shouldn't
vote t-shirt today they will be
delivered at the end of this month so
make sure you sign up and get your
T-shirt today day the first clip was um
something that I saw I think it's was on
YouTube shorts or Tik Tok or something
and it was a video of Andrew claven from
the daily wire talking about marriage
and as I've said the men from the daily
wire are very out of touch on this issue
they have no idea what is going on in
the dating market today and while I am
happy for them that they don't have to
deal with this craziness um it's funny
because they'll call me out of touch and
say I don't know what I'm talking about
yet none of them have participated in
the dating Market in decades literally
decades me on the other hand I've
interviewed thousands of people that
have given me their opinions on dating
and relationships I I think a lot of
times while they mean well they go into
marriage very naive so I want to pull
this clip that I saw of Andrew let's
what would you consider a prenup prenups
are regularly thrown out all the time
they're typically non- enforceable
especially the longer the marriage goes
on the less likely they are to be
enforced men get absolutely destroyed in
marriage and in divorce 50% of marriages
end in divorce 80% of divorces are
initiated by women 90% if she's college
educated 90% of child support payments
go from men to women 97% of alimony
payments go from men to women you know
you have no fault to divorce so a woman
can cheat on you she can still get half
your [__] first of all it's 40% of first
marriages so 50% the 50% thing you'd
have to add people who get serially
divorced and you shouldn't marry one of
those so that's not a good argument for
not getting married it's a good argument
for not marrying somebody you're going
to have to divorce the way to do that
make sure she's a conservative goes to
church and is a virgin then you're not
going to get divorced you'll be fine
okay so all right a couple things I like
how he's fighting for this 10% he's like
guys guys guys you guys are doomers it's
not
50% it's 40% of first marriages and I
want to talk about a couple things that
he really I would argue has not
considered so one thing that he has not
considered is that the stats today
include the people that are over the age
of 30 40 50 and 60 and I don't really
think he takes into account how much
social media has influenced the culture
and women in particular so I've said
this before and I'll say it again I
believe that attention to women is the
same thing as sex to men you know and
how I came to this conclusion is if you
ask women if you could be beautiful the
rest of your life you could look 22 the
rest of your life but you would never
sleep with anyone again most women would
pick the beauty over getting to sleep
with
someone um I don't know say Jason mimoa
or whoever it is right where men on the
other hand wouldn't pick the looks they
typically would pick sleeping with the
hot chicks which it it shows us
something that we intrinsically Desire
with women desire to be desired where
men desire to you know have a lot of a
lot of hot chicks you know what I mean
we we value different things there's a
reason that men brag about the women
they've slept with and women don't
there's a reason that women will brag
about the men that have dm'd them or
given them attention at one point or
another where so they're completely
different things now you have to take
into account even the young Christian
virgin chick likely has had access to
social media from a young age so he
hasn't really taken into account how one
the women from 12 years old have had
excess social media and sometimes even
younger in this new generation like um I
think I was talking to Christine she
said for her like they got smartphones
around nine 9 years old that is so young
that completely changes your brain so I
would argue that it's actually going to
be much more grim and it also doesn't
take into account the people didn't get
legally married and just did the
long-term liveing relationship thing and
then ended up getting divorced or
breaking up whatever the other thing
that I don't think he really takes into
account is female nature I'm sorry but
women always have leverage in
relationships in 2023 and there is no
evidence that suggests that women do the
right thing when they get leveraged
we're more prone to violence when we get
leverag we've passed a bunch of
discriminatory policies and he just says
go find a virgin chick and I actually
don't even necessarily disagree with
them I mean that is the best odds for
success but I'm sorry Andrew I have I
get messages every day from guys that
married the Virgin chick that did the
exact same thing and the issue is you
cannot control the culture women we tend
to go with what's trendy um there's a
reason we we get the latest fashion
trends like one year you'll see like
these puffy sleeves one year you'll see
women will have literal holes in their
sleeves big holes in jeans and you think
why do women do that well we always do
what's cool we always do what's trendy
it's why we have the duck lips now the
Botox forehead all this nonsense even
the virgins of today are not the virgins
of yesterday because the problem is when
you when there is a unicorn the line
that piles up for that unicorn changes
the woman most women do not do the right
thing and they go crazy when they get
excess attention you can see examples of
this where wholesome women like when
Miley Cyrus she was kind of a wholesome
chick from the
Midwest and then she goes crazy Britney
Spear is another one all of these chicks
that get excessive attention from a
young age go crazy they go insane women
are not meant to do that and so the
issue is Andrew says basically find a
unicorn well Andrew only 4% of women
wait till they're married that's not
enough to go around that would still
leave a large portion of
men W without a wife to pick from and
what I'm saying is actually biblical
because it says in the Bible that men
are better to live alone than with a
quarrelsome wife well what if all of the
women on the market are
quarrelsome and the other thing is most
women have never been taught what it
means to be a wife most women have never
been taught about submission most women
have never been taught these things
so Andrew is basically saying just find
a
unicorn and find a girl that prays and
therefore you will have great odds um he
then says 40% chance um and even the
other thing
is I want to say I can't remember it off
the top of my head but it was roughly
like 40% of people that get divorced are
religious and then this is like the The
Comeback you'll always
see they're not real religious they're
not the real Catholics they're the real
Christians and then it gets into a funny
place where we're kind of playing God
who are you to decide who is the real
Christians and real Catholics I mean are
you without sin I'm not without sin how
how do you know um the only thing you
can really do is ask people and
obviously maybe you say let's say 10% or
20% aren't real even if it's a 20%
chance of divorce divor you know that's
a 20% chance of living hell for a guy I
mean I think I think it's pretty much
hell to a guy to have to watch another
man raise his kids and that is the
situation a lot of men are in where a
stranger is going to have more of an
influence and an impact on his children
than he will okay so the comment section
had a lot to say um the old dude said it
so casually like we are still in his era
um blood 4939 says conservative that
goes to church and is a virgin like that
is so easy in this era yes and Andrew I
have interviewed thousands of people
thousands like literally I've been
interviewing people on the streets in
person for
years do you know how many virgin chicks
I've met that I actually believe because
you know you also get the ones that say
they are but are super
argumentative and disagreeable so you
know a virgin isn't even uh a a spiteful
virgin isn't even ideal 4% of women are
virgins on their wedding
days that still accounts for the
argumentative virgins the fat virgins
this isn't what men want okay but
anyways out of thousands of interviews
you know how many I found one one and
you can't even tell me that we're
picking for special chicks no Andrew no
Andrew this is the culture this is the
new world more there are more only fans
models than teachers now women that are
fake wives spend money on themselves and
they get BOTOX and they wouldn't need to
get BOTOX if they knew that one of the
leading reasons that skin begins to Sag
and formor wrinkles isn't necessarily
because of old age but because our
bodies are missing out on essential
collagen you see we produce 10% less
collagen every decade once we hit 30 and
that's a major reason behind those pesky
wrink Les that's why myself along with
tens of thousands of people have turned
to this cuttingedge new substance to
help reduce visible signs of aging it
uses the top five most researched types
of collagen which which is essential for
skin Health to support skin elasticity
and skin hydration the best part I love
is that you get 53% off for the rest of
the month or until they sell out
whatever comes first get yours now by
going to health withth pear.com that's
health withth pear.com you will not
regret it you know I wanted to give some
examples of fake wives now fake wives
are all throughout Hollywood and we have
the more obvious ones like Jada
obviously um but you know every now and
then I'll see a clip and and there's
little telltale signs that you can tell
that is a fake wife let's pull it up
along and so I didn't commit commit in
fact until he proposed to me there was
no real commitment as such even if we
were technically allowed to maybe see
other people yeah we would just keep
coming back to each other uh look at
second unfair to me or to the other
person or to the relationship itself I
think um I'm not someone who's been
frivolous in relationships I take my
relationships very seriously and when
I'm in one I'd like to give it 100% And
I don't think I'm ready for that
technically allowed to maybe see other
people we would just keep coming back to
each other um
so
yeah so what does this mean what does
this translate too he was the safe guy
she knew that she could basically do
whatever she wanted and he wouldn't
leave she still she wanted to sleep
around with the guys that she was
actually attracted to and get the
resources from him that's a fake wife
because when you think of femininity
what what is femininity is that is that
a feminine thing to do to want to date
all of these
people and then have your the guy that
you marry on the back burner so some of
the comments say deep DEA I don't even
know how to say this DEA
padukon DEA PUK I'm sorry guys the most
fakest personality that exists in
Bollywood and I actually I don't even
know where this chick is from I don't
know Bollywood um someone said maybe
different phases of her life back then
that's what she thought giving 100% to a
relationship after having three to four
relationships that none of them worked
she was in the phase where she wanted a
casual relationship I guess we all
humans do that it's not just recorded
and I think it's gone on for a while I
think there's a reason that dads would
protect their daughters from certain
guys and say stay away from my daughter
and obedient daughters right that that
were more F like because feminine women
are obedient so obedient daughters would
listen to their father and the
disobedient daughters would end up in a
single motherhood or a shotgun wedding
um and that's what the red pill talks
about they really just look at patterns
of behavior with women and the thing is
a lot of women don't have genuine desire
for their husbands their husband was the
safe fallback guy and a lot of times
women treat him as such even if that is
true why is this woman publicly saying
that why why are you embarrassing your
guy and the problem is
one none of the men check the women so
they don't even tell the women how out
of line that is and two we've gone
through a society where that's like cute
funny and it's not it's not cute it's
not funny and that's embarrassing to
your husband i' also talk about how the
last generation of real wives
really are are women between the ages of
roughly 70 to 90 and I I'm not saying
there aren't real wives after that there
totally were but let's just say women
between the ages of 70 to 90 let's say
70% were real wives then we go down to
the women between the ages of 40 to 60
now 40% are real wives then we go to the
women under the age of 40 maybe 20% are
real wives now what's a real wife a real
wife is a woman that submits to serves
and obeys her husband number one a real
wife does not get divorced she doesn't
believe in it and she will make the
relationship work at all costs even at
the expense of
herself what is important to a real wife
is the family she does not spend money
on Botox on the latest fashion trends
the only thing she cares about is
looking good for her husband she's not
posting on social media she's not
seeking validation and attention from
other men that is a real
wife now I I have no idea how this woman
acts in her relationships but what I do
see from the older generation is the
ability to be honest and be real and I
saw this hilarious Grandma um basically
being put on like a vice type panel with
some weirdos let's pull gay ask how he
identifies how do you identify actually
identify as uh oh here we go it's that
long plethora of oh my God wait for I
will let me get a
chair somebody please reach out to this
women woman we need her on the show
please tell me where I can find her that
is hilarious that is so
funny and that that's the
thing they didn't grow up with this
nonsense so it's semi all this craziness
started I remember when I was in college
like that was like the that was when the
Bruce Jenner stuff came out that was
when all of the left woke [__] [__]
started to come out when I was in
college when I was in high school I
don't remember much of it so I can't
even imagine being like 70 80 90 years
old and seeing how much the culture has
switched where everyone used to have
families and get married and maybe
because you know the 70s still like the
the crazy 60s and 70s still existed but
you know it was still normal to you know
maybe they would do crazy stuff when
they were young but they would still get
married and have a family where in my
generation most women probably will not
have a a family most women if they do
have children it will not be under the
context of marriage so people that are
70 80 90 years old have really seen the
degradation of the culture so the
comment section says she's seen a lot of
BS in her day and she ain't having none
of this BS I love it Judge Judy's sister
is a real Savage yeah oh my gosh someone
needs to make judge Judy a YouTube
channel and the reason I think my
generation is so confused is because
they have lied to us we have been fed
egalitarian nonsense our entire lives
now what is egalitarianism I'll give you
an example it's all about balance what
does that mean my opinion is just as
important as my husband's no no no no
your opinion is not as important as your
husband's I believe in patriarchy I
believe in submitting to men's Authority
relationships do not work
otherwise there are people that still
stay together but the relationship is
out of order and you can typically see
that in the children the woman has to
respect the man she has to otherwise it
does not work that the man has to come
before the children and before yourself
it is always the man first and that is
what we have been taught wrong is
egality it arianism you should have an
equal say your opinion matters and then
we wonder why we're so confused and our
generation can't make it work um and so
there's a street interview of a woman
being asked who comes first her child
her husband or her father let's pull it
up who comes first your son your husband
or your dad let me tell you something my
husband he's number one he's number one
who's number two my child and then your
dad but then my dad yes why your dad
last though
my dad would be first if I wasn't
married okay so even if you're married
why him
last because my mama got
him okay my mama got him I don't have to
hold him down my mom's salid say sh but
he's your dad though he's my dad but my
mom's 100 and she's 15 years younger
than my daddy I should never have to
take care of my daddy it's on her type
[__] it's on her and she a Scorpio she
holds it the [__] down my mom lies her
virginity to my daddy they've been
together for 50 years so they doing what
they supposed to she's right yes yes yes
relationships and family structures do
not work unless the husband is put first
he has to come before the children
because what happens if she doesn't put
the husband first the entire family
breaks down and typically you can see it
in the children I'll give you an example
before the Jada and will debacle
happened before the famous slap before
Jada talked about Tupac before the
entanglement before all of that people
loved Will and Jada that look of love
that I was looking at right there
between you and your husband I love it I
need to rub a little bit that hey that's
what 20 years will get you I know I know
who I know who's here after 20 years she
knows your s I know the touch I know the
scent I know the energy everything I
told her we were just talking about that
I said that look of love that I saw when
you all walked onto this carpet my
goodness you know CH cuz we've survived
you know yeah we've survived you know
and it's the that that's the thing that
is difficult that people don't
understand about love you think it's all
flowers and everything but love gets
created by making it together people
loved Will and Jada I remember having
this conversation with my mom a couple
years ago and I said something is wrong
in that household something is off
because their kids are weird and you
will see this in households with weak
fathers you will absolutely see they
could be together but if you have a weak
father that is why you see Bill Gates
daughter seems to be going the direction
of being a [__] I think I don't know
but based on what I've seen the same
thing with the Obama's kids you know
they're coming out they're fat she
they're smoking drugs or whatever where
you know Trump is
divorced but his kids turned out a hell
of a lot better when you have a dad that
actually doesn't take [__] from the
women and actually leads his household
you cannot tell me that Trump is not a
leader and it is not going to be what he
says goes in the household and you see
even though he's three times divorced
his kids turned out a hell of a lot
better than a married family where the
husband tolerates disrespect if you
tolerate disrespect from your wife you
are teaching your kids that and now you
have a situation where Will's kid is
crying over Tupac and publicly
disrespecting him so she's actually
absolutely right where the husband has
to come first and what happens if the
relationship breaks down the kid's more
likely to be home homeless the kid's
more likely to drop out of school the
kid is more likely to commit crimes if
the dad doesn't come first then the
whole family breaks down and this is
actually why I question why women and
children get on the boats first I know
and no this is this is gonna this is
very out of left field but I question if
that's really correct because when you
think about it if the men aren't saved
then Society crumbles and they'll always
argue that like one man can impregnate a
whole island or whatever
but you still need men to protect
Society from other people otherwise
they'll just kill the guy and grab the
women so when you think about it if the
the family unit is going to break
anyways because okay think think about
it like this think about it like this
the ship's going down the man sacrifices
his life for the women and the children
this is just me thinking out loud guys
well then what what happens well then
the new guy comes in and kills the kid I
mean that that's what would happen in
the animal kingdom right the new guy
comes in the kids's gone or the kid's so
messed up like the daughter becomes a
[__] because she doesn't have a dad or
the daughter
becomes crazy or whatever now we have
more crazy
people
so I question if that's even right and
then you get rid of all the men the men
make all of the Innovations in society
they protect Society
why is the magical womb you know men
have gotten so far they might even be
able to create wombs that's how talented
men are so I actually question the
notion if the men are supposed to lay
down their lives for their family
because you know or like they they
should go down where the because like
it's almost out of order when you think
about it I don't know I'm just that
that's more of a a thought I've had
recently is that really the correct way
is that way in order why do the women
and the children get on the boat but not
the men it seems a bit out of order
you'd almost you'd almost think it would
be better to have like I don't know the
top five families get on you know I I
don't know I'm just thinking here okay
so the first comments are from women
they say husband over your child oh no
oh baby Nar what is n a r no I don't
know why why can't we spell as chicks
all right no man is coming before my
child gorgeous gem says and this is why
we have so many failed relationships the
husband has to come first the Bible says
husband comes first good for her yo it's
Gabby um my child is number one my dad
is number two my husband is number three
that is the only right answer and I bet
if we clicked on their profiles they
would be fat single women because guys I
don't make the rules people want to say
that pearls so mean I'm just telling you
the truth and relationships only work if
the woman submits to the man's Authority
um and women are so focused on
themselves they're focused on their
Botox on their fake nails fake hair that
they forget that one of the leading
reasons that skin begins to Sag and form
wrinkles is not necessarily because of
old age but because our bodies are
missing out on essential collagen you
see we produce 10% less collagen every
decade once we hit 30 and that's a major
reason behind those pesty wrinkles
adding just a little collagen to your
diet can have noticeable effects on your
skin and youthfulness preferably the
sooner the better that's why myself
along with tens of thousands of people
have turned to this Cutting Edge new
substance to help reduce visible signs
of aging it uses the top five most
researched types of collagen which is
essential for your skin health to
support skin elasticity and skin
hydration the five collagen types are
difficult to find on their own but
they're all included in every scoop just
mix a serving with your favorite morning
drink to give skin the building blocks
it needs to reignite a youthful glow the
best part guys is you get 53% off for
the rest of the month or until they sell
out whatever comes first you'll also
receive additional gifts valued over
$500 with a free order for every limited
time including free V IP live health and
fitness coaching for Life a free new
ebook titled the 14 foods for amazing
skin a 60-day satisfaction guaranteed
with free shipping get yours now by
going to health with.com that's Health
with.com you will not regret it okay so
you know I've talked about how the
culture has shifted in the last hundred
years now mind you when the suffer Jets
came out in the 1920s when these crazy
ladies came out they were not well-liked
now that's a 100 years ago roughly you
know the people between the ages of 80
to 100 have seen so much you know they
lived in a time where really America was
a different place the average number of
kids was six four four to six
roughly um and back then you got married
and you stayed married everything
changed in the 70s with the development
of birth control and the free love
movement but the movement started in the
20s um the first sexual Revolution was
in the 20s but it was not as crazy as it
is
today so there was a video of Michael
nolles talking about his high school
sweetheart let's pull it up everyone
around the table was supposed to say how
they met their partner so they go around
and Tinder zap or whatever and I said my
wife and I met we don't remember it was
either Home Room in middle school or a
district Orchestra in elementary school
the girls were dead silent just staring
at me slacked you I said what okay
you're not not a very romantic crowd
here huh and they said oh I assumed you
were kidding they couldn't believe that
somebody would marry his high school
sweetheart like that wasn't even a
possibility 40 years ago that would be
the norm think about how radically the
culture is changed and then what did
they do they all said a so there's this
longing especially among young women for
some semblance of traditional normal
life they know it's a good thing they're
longing for that okay so one yes he is
right about how much the culture has
changed but Michael I got to be honest
with
you if women were longing for
traditionalism they would would pick it
and this is where the daily wire has an
innate they they have this in and you
see it in their language that they pick
they're they still have a gynocentric
worldview he thinks that women are these
innocent creatures that have this
longing they just have this longing for
traditionalism Michael then why don't
they pick it women have the most agency
around 22 men have the most agency let's
say
32 women when they have the most Choice
are not choosing to get married the
average age of first marriage is 30 in
the United States it's 31 in England
it's actually 35 in countries like
Ireland and some parts of Eastern Europe
women don't have this longing for
traditionalism because we're not picking
it now I think a lot of times women we
pick what's fun at the time what's
entertaining and then don't understand
the consequences that come with it later
but my question for Michael if women
really longed for this if they really
wanted this why aren't they picking it
and that's how guys you can tell who
still has like a gynocentric worldview
and the gentric worldview will always
say that women are so special and they
almost talk about the feminine like it's
God it's Godlike like women just have
this amazing like nurturing like how are
women I I don't believe women are are
more nurturing I'm sorry I'm sorry guys
women do favors and then throw it in
your face
later yeah I think men M are much more
genuine in their kindness I don't think
it's kind to do a favor for someone and
bring it up later and for life just say
I did this for you did this did this did
this women are much more likely to do
that yes um I I don't I I don't buy it
we're more likely to kill infants we're
more likely to kill the elderly
I I just I think men are actually much
Kinder and more nurturing sorry guys I I
just don't see it and what you're going
to notice is whenever they say something
positive about women it's always
something that can't be measured so
you'll notice they'll say women are more
nurturing and then I'll say Well then
why are they more likely to kill their
children they'll say men are the violent
ones and I'll say well why are they the
ones that kill the
innocent the positive things about women
always cannot be measured I believe that
women are the weaker vessel I believe
that men are significantly smarter than
women and while there are special and
amazing women I I don't think there's
anything about female nature that's just
so magical it and you guys hear it in
the language it's feminine language the
way they talk about female nature it's
like this magical special nature you
know it's gynocentric to me but anyways
there is a comment on this video that
says my husband and I met when we were
babies a year and a half old and 3 years
old when my family moved into the
neighborhood we lived across the street
from each other in a culdesac and we
were together literally every day since
then we grew up as best friends got
married at 16 and 17 years old and I've
been married 42 years and have five kids
ages 22 to 40 and five grandkids I can't
imagine being without each other oh
that's so cute typically when people
meet young um they're over the age
of 35
40 it's really not something you see
anymore and I would say that's because
of the Advent of social media social
media has given access to women to
higher and higher status men and they
tend we tend to go after them all right
so we have a new segment where we read
the top comment from the last video so
if you guys have a comment that you want
read here on the show leave it below and
like your favorite comment to vote for
what comic read next time George Maul
says how about Taylor Swift is the
highest paid musician of all time and
she says she's oppressed in the music
industry I despise this
woman yes oh gosh and that's the thing
privilege is invisible to those who have
it and pretty women will not see the
privilege of their beauty until it's
gone and then they'll blame the
patriarchy for losing what made their
career in the beginning because if
Taylor Swift was ugly she would have a
very different career but let me know
what you guys think in the comments like
your favorite comment in the comment
section below get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt and I'll talk to
you guys next time